GENERAL, ONE COULD ONLY IMAGINE
WHAT HE WOULD HAVE DONE HAD HE
BEEN IN UNIFORM IN THIS PERIOD.
RYAN NOBLES ON CAPITOL HILL,
THANK YOU.
JOINING US, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
JONATHAN MARTIN AND ALEX BURNS.
THEY HAVE OBTAINED NEVER BEFORE
HEARD AUDIO OF KEVIN McCARTHY
RIGHT AFTER THE INSURRECTION.
THEY ALSO HAVE A NEW BOOK COMING
OUT ON MAY 3rd THAT HAS MADE
QUITE A LOT OF NOISE, TITLED,
THIS WILL NOT PASS, TRUMP,
BIDEN, AND THE BATTLE FOR
AMERICA'S FUTURE.
THANKS FOR SHARING FIRST ON "THE
LEAD."
LET'S START BY PLAYING THE
AUDIO.
>> THE OTHER THING I WANT TO
BRING UP, AND I'M MAKING SOME
PHONE CALLS TO SOME MEMBERS.
I JUST GOT SOMETHING SENT NOW
ABOUT NEWS FROM MATT GAETZ WHERE
HE'S CALLING PEOPLE'S NAMES OUT,
SAYING ANTI-TRUMP AND THIS TYPE
OF ATMOSPHERE.
AND SOME OF THE OTHER PLACES.
THIS IS SERIOUS STUFF PEOPLE ARE
DOING THAT HAS TO STOP.
>> MO AND LOUIS'S COMMENTS, A
LOT OF MEMBERS HAVE SAID SOME
REAL CONCERNING THINGS.
>> DID THEY SAY SOMETHING TODAY,
TOO?
>> MO WAS AT THE RALLY.
THE KICKING ASS AND TAKING NAMES
THING AT THE TRUMP RALLY.
>> THIS IS MORE.
>> WHAT DID GAETZ SAY?
>> GAETZ SAID, GAETZ ON THAT
LIST SPECIFICALLY, I SAW THAT ON
TWITTER.
>> SOMEONE JUST SENT IT.
GONZALEZ JUST SENT IT TO ME SO
I'M CALLING GAETZ, EXPLAINING TO
HIM.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE'LL SAY BUT
I'M GOING TO HAVE OTHER PEOPLE
CALL HILL.
THE NATURE, IF I'M GETTING
BRIEFING, I'M GOING TO GET
ANOTHER ONE FROM THE FBI
TOMORROW, THIS IS SERIOUS SHIT.
CUT THIS OUT.
>> YEAH, THAT'S -- POTENTIALLY
ILLEGAL WHAT HE'S DOING.
>> WELL, HE'S PUTTING PEOPLE IN
JEOPARDY.
AND HE DOESN'T NEED TO BE DOING
THIS.
WE SAW WHAT PEOPLE WOULD DO IN
THE CAPITOL.
YOU KNOW, AND THESE PEOPLE CAME
PREPARED.
ALONG WITH EVERYTHING ELSE.
>> MAN, SO ALEX, LET ME START
WITH YOU.
TELL US THE BACKSTORY HERE.
>> WELL, THE BACKSTORY IS THIS
IS ANOTHER PIECE OF THE PHONE
CALL THAT KEVIN McCARTY HELD
WITH SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSE REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP
TEAM, AND YOU HEARD ALSO THE
VOICES OF A NUMBER OF STAFF
MEMBERS.
FOUR DAYS AFTER THE JANUARY 6th
INSURRECTION, AND THEY'RE
TALKING THROUGH THE BEHAVIOR OF
SOME OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE.
YOU HEARD HIM TALK ABOUT MATT
GAETZ BY NAME.
WHAT WE REPORT IN OUR BOOK IS IN
THIS PERIOD, KEVIN McCARTHY AND
OTHER REPUBLICAN LEADERS WERE
PRETTY CLEAR EYED AT LEAST IN
PRIVATE ABOUT THE VERY SERIOUS
SECURITY THREAT THAT THEY SAW
COMING FROM THE FAR RIGHT OF THE
HOUSE REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE.
THE NAMING AND ATTACKING OF
ANTI-TRUMP REPUBLICANS LIKE LIZ
CHENEY, LIKE ADAM KINZINGER,
SOME OF THE CONTINUING VERY
OVERHEATED RHETORIC CLAIMING
FALSELY THAT THE 2020 ELECTION
WAS STOLEN.
AND OTHER OFFENSIVE COMMENTS
LOOKING BACK AT THOSE RALLIES,
THAT RALLY ON THE ELLIPSE ON
JANUARY 6th, AND THEN COMMENTS
ON TWITTER AND TELEVISION SINCE
THEN WHERE KEVIN McCARTHY MAKES
NO BONES ABOUT IT.
HE THINKS THIS IS PUTTING PEOPLE
IN JEOPARDY.
>> HE DOESN'T SAY THAT PUBLICLY.
PUBLICLY, HE'S VERY SUBMISSIVE
TO THE FAR RIGHT OF HIS PARTY.
JONATHAN, I WANT TO PLAY ANOTHER
MOMENT WHERE McCARTHY IS
EXPRESSING CONCERN.
LET'S ROLL THAT TAPE.
>> THE OTHER THING THAT WE HAVE
TO DO IS THESE NUMBERS ON
WHATEVER POSITION YOU ARE,
CALLING OUT OTHER MEMBERS,
THAT'S GOT TO STOP, ESPECIALLY
IN THIS NATURE.
SO WHEN I GET OFF, I'M GOING TO
CALL GAETZ.
ANYTHING ELSE WE SEE, DON'T
ASSUME I SEE EVERYTHING.
DON'T ASSUME I KNOW EVERYTHING.
BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE ONE CENTRAL
POINT, SO I MEAN, IF YOU CAN
BRING THIS STUFF TO VAN SO HE
CAN HAVE IT, BUT IT'S GOING TO
BE PERSONALLY, TENSION IS TOO
HIGH, THE COUNTRY IS TOO CRAZY.
I DO NOT WANT TO LOOK BACK AND
THINK WE CAUSED SOMETHING OR WE
MISSED SOMETHING AND SOMEONE GOT
HURT.
I DON'T WANT TO PLAY POLITICS
WITH ANY OF THAT.
>> SO THIS WAS JANUARY 10th,
JUST A FEW DAYS AFTER THE
CAPITOL RIOT.
EXPLAIN WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE.
>> THIS IS KEVIN McCARTHY
CLEARLY SOBER ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th, AND
ALSO DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF A REPEAT.
SEE HIS FAR RIGHT NUMBERS SAY
INCENDIARY THINGS ONLINE AND ON
THE AIR AND REALLY CONCERNED
THAT'S GOING TO CAUSE MORE
BLOODSHED, MORE POLITICAL
VIOLENCE IN AMERICA.
THESE ARE EXTRAORDINARY DAYS.
THIS PERIOD IN HISTORY.
AND WHAT YOU HEAR THERE IN THAT
MOMENT IS KEVIN McCARTHY VOWING
TO CRACK DOWN ON MATT GAETZ.
HE'S TELLING HIS FELLOW GOP
LEADERS I'M GOING TO TALK TO
HIM.
I'M GOING TO TALK TO MATT GAETZ.
WE HAVE TO CUT THIS S OUT.
HE SAID CUT THE SHIT OUT.
YOU HEARD THERE ON THE AUDIO.
OF COURSE, 15 MONTHS LATER,
JAKE, WHAT'S HAPPENED IS KEVIN
McCARTHY AT EVERY TURN HAS
ACQUIESCED TO PEOPLE LIKE
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE AND MATT
GAETZ BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL NOT TOLERATE ANY CRITICISM
OF THOSE MEMBERS BECAUSE THEY'RE
HIS CLOSES